hey ross you ready to sing some carol
i don't know if you can handle this
carol
we're gonna contact three women all
right
and zoom bomb right into their meeting
with the producer and they have no idea
we're doing this that we're going to pop
in not
a clue are you warmed up me me me me me
me
i would love for you to share just a
little bit about
everything that you're doing i am a girl
scout leader which is amazing i've been
doing that for five years
it's important for girls today
especially with so many different
dynamics in the world
that they stay powerful and true to
their self dashing through the snow
with a one
[Music]
we were pitching at the end there
rebecca but hi
hi you are the mother of six
children i am it is
so hard but we manage we all pitch in
together we all
like love unconditionally the tone
you're setting for your family
it's so good can you tell me
a little bit about all of the great
things that you're doing
and working towards becoming a social
service worker so that i can
help kids even better the goal is to
have my own drama school that's therapy
based
and i would love to focus mostly with
kids who
have experienced bullying and abuse
you meet you i can't believe it i love
you drew i love you
too what you're doing in your work is
vital you're involving yourself in
people's lives and trying
to make them better at an age that they
are being
formed tell me why it's so important for
you to give and what organizations
you're working with
every year we work with toys for tots
and we
finished getting a lot of donations for
the humane society and now we're
looking for donations for the homeless
veterans in atlanta
what's your daughter's name drew she's
named after drew barrymore
i'm a fan and drew has always inspired
me
a christmas tree oh christmas oh my god
i can't believe
that lovely so unchanging
are you gonna change your daughter's
name now no no no no no no
whenever i've had a rough time i find
something in something you say and
my life would not be the same without
you i
reached out to you to bring some cheer
never could i have imagined that i would
receive such kindness in your words
i hope to live up to them boy a little
comedic christmas jingle really turned
into something much bigger and more
important than i could have imagined so
thank you so much
[Music]
you